Stephen A Smith a fixture of ESPN's NBA
coverage but it's his opinions on the
show first take that agree or disagree
keep folks coming back for more I worked
with Smith for years at ESPN and knew
there was more to him than loud opinions
but there was so much that I never knew
until now which he shares in straight
shooter A Memoir of Second Chances and
first takes published by Paramount's
Simon Schuster please please just be
quiet and listen because let me tell you
something you don't know what the hell
you talking about as a verbal sparring
partner Stephen A Smith is Relentless
what the hell are you talking about I'm
talking about cultures
loquacious this ain't politics baby this
is sports persuasive and opinionated I'm
telling you right now you can't do it
can't do it can't do it can't do it not
that put another way a straight shooter
the Dallas Mavericks are a mess now you
can refute it you can deny it you can
counter it you can debate it but you
know I mean what I say he keeps that
signature style in his duly named Memoir
while also revealing a surprisingly
softer side why did you want to be so
revealing and so real
I thought I owed it to the audience out
there whoever they may be this is why I
am the way that I am
Anthony Smith what's up everybody the
youngest of six was raised in Hollis
Queens
a residential Enclave on the outskirts
of New York City
[Music]
known for hip-hop legends from Russell
Simmons to Run DMC
place at the center of Smith's story but
at the heart of it is his mom Janet
Smith my mother for the first 45 years
of my life on this Earth told me she
loved me maybe three times but I knew it
every day because everything and I mean
everything she did
was about loving me is amazing because
I'm in this business and I speak all the
time and I'm talking my mother was not
about to talk
she was about actions it's five and a
half years that she's been gone I cried
every day for two years
I went to therapy because of my mother
there's nothing else in life that could
have convinced me to go to therapy in
Smith's words she was everything working
as a nurse 16 hours a day seven days a
week to pay the bills as much as she
gave he says his father took we weren't
poor because we weren't making money
we were poor because my father chose to
take his money and spend it on a
different family which left us in an
incredible bind where you had holes on
the roof rats and roaches in the house
barely any food in the refrigerator I
love them I always will
um but I have very little respect for
him the one thing his father provided
Smith a love of sports it was a form of
competition for me not only did I get to
a point where I would talk to him about
those Sports eventually I would debate
with him about it and ultimately I would
be superior to him because I would watch
more games than him so he got to a point
where he was relying on me to tell him
what happened and when he did that his
respect for me elevated and sports did
that for me
Smith grew up playing on the basketball
courts at P.S 192 near his house he
would end up playing college ball at
Winston-Salem State University until an
injury ended his playing career so my
mother sits down being a straight
shooter as she was and she said so much
for that Basketball Dream that's not
going to happen
so now what is it that you're going to
do with your life the first words that
popped out of my mouth is I'm going to
be on television I'll be a sportscaster
she was like okay well
Winston-Salem doesn't have a broadcast
journalism class I mean what are you
going to do with a West Indian accent
and I said
well I write for the school newspaper
his first article was on how his coach
Clarence big house Gaines should retire
at the time Smith was still on the team
and there were people that were really
mad at you sure assistant coaches wanted
me thrown off the team and Coach Gates
told everybody to back up he said he
told me what he was going to write he
told me why he came to me and asked for
permission to do it and I told him to go
ahead that's what journalism is all
about be fair
be Humane be decent but call it like you
see it Smith rode his way to larger
papers and roles working as a news and
sports reporter before earning a coveted
Sports columnist post at the
Philadelphia Enquirer brace yourself I'm
gonna defend Kobe Bryant in 2003 ESPN
came calling his dream TV job but it was
Smith's dismissal six years later he
says forever changed him the best way I
can say it is that it made me a better
man
not just a better professional but a
better man how when ESPN let me go I
felt I got screwed
I went home but it wasn't to my house in
South Jersey home to me was going back
home the way I grew up
in my bunk bed in my mother's house two
days I just laid in bed that third
morning she comes up to me and she gives
me my bagel and she brought me it on a
tray and on the tray she had a handheld
mirror and she said
I'm just wondering when you're gonna
look at yourself she was like I didn't
raise you to be somebody that didn't
accept accountability there is no way on
Earth that everything could be their
fault and she closed the door and left
and
all I did for the next 24 hours or so
was think about everything that I did
wrong and I just said you know what I
deserve this this is not who I am and
from that point forward put myself on a
path to resurrect my career Smith worked
his way back to ESPN you cannot beat
Kevin Durant and lose in the first round
happened
eventually taking over the show he's now
best known for First Take This Is Me
with Chadwick Boseman when I met him he
came on first take over the years Smith
has reached a status on par with
professional athletes and celebrities I
consider Jamie Foxx maybe the greatest
talent in the history of Hollywood
because of his versatility he gets on me
from time to time but he's always right
I know he is he is Jamie you heard that
just in case he's always right and of
course this is my brother Sir Charles
right here here so is he always right no
absolutely not he keeps a collection of
signed jerseys of course this is Bubba
Chuck himself to Great Allen Iverson and
of the greatest of all time Michael
Jordan sent me his jersey he scares me
because this dude is obviously the goat
in my eyes there is no other he doesn't
talk
well he's one of them this is the man
cave and it's there that he keeps an eye
on the Sports World it really dissect
what I'm in and what's going on before I
go on the air the next day
whether it's on his podcast tackling
issues from politics to culture I want
to go to a deeper subject or 10 plus
hours a week of live sports TV Stephen A
Smith has no plans to stop writing or
speaking his mind after all why should
he I'm not expressing an opinion to
convince you that I'm right I'm telling
you I'm right and daring you to prove me
wrong there's a difference but people
are still going to be mad sure and
they're going to be mad at you sure
you're okay with it I'm totally fine
with it because I did my job I'm going
to be fair I'm going to be Humane I'm
going to call it like I see it and as
long as I know that I'm that person I
sleep very well at night